well it is the first day of black
history month and a great way to
celebrate here locally is by learning
how black leaders have contributed to
our
very own las vegas history rocky is live
at a popular vegas attraction where you
can do
just that hey rocky
hey you guys yeah jc this is kind of
like the black history month version of
sin city chronicles right can you hear
the buzzing it kind of gives you a hint
as to where we are we are at the neon
museum here with don the vice president
of the neon museum welcome to the show
let's let's start talking about
the restoration of the moulin rouge side
before we get to the black history
lesson here all right well this sign is
beautiful obviously
we restored it well we restored the neon
on it late last year
and as you can see it's a little bit
different colored so the red stuff at
the top
that's the old neon from 1955 and the
stuff that's more pink
are the new signs it's one of our
favorite signs and we're so glad that we
were able to restore it and you can hear
the buzz of the neon
which very exciting so let's start
walking and talking here because now
it's time
to get into the black history lesson
here because one of the best ways to
celebrate you guys
around town is to just learn how it is
relevant to our own city right
absolutely so what's the story of the
moulin rouge the moulin rouge is very
significant
because it was the first racially
integrated hotel in las vegas
when black entertainers came to town
they could perform on the strip but they
couldn't stay on the strip
so they would go to the moulin rouge and
the rat pack were famous for going to
the moulin rouge for their 2 30 a.m
performance
and the place was packed it was very
very popular
but it wasn't open for very long luckily
we have the sign here
you can come you can learn all about it
and why it was important in las vegas
history
and i understand there was a really
important meeting that happened at the
moulin rouge let's talk about that
yeah well in the 19 in 1960 governor
grant sawyer called a meeting with
the naacp with leading west side leaders
leading and he wanted them to try to
come to an agreement
on ending segregation in las vegas and
that's what started the end of
segregation in las vegas it was a slow
process but ultimately it finally went
away as it should have
wow that is an incredible story and
that's just a start we have so many
other
places to take you um during this day
here celebrating black history month at
the neon museum so what are some of the
other signs
that people will get a chance to see
well we have the fitzgerald
we have the silver slipper and we have
la concha they're all very significant
so we have a lot of great stories to
share and when people come down to
celebrate with you guys what's the
process what is there a tour guide
that'll take them through we have a
couple of things you can come on
general admission which is what we have
right now you can walk around at your
leisure
we have folks stationed throughout the
yard that can share information with you
or you can book a guided tour that takes
place in the evening when you can really
see the lights popping
and they tell you the stories of las
vegas and the significant impact
that the black community has on our
collection i cannot wait
i kind of i'm working yes i'm working
but i'm also one of you guys sitting at
home because i'm learning too so thank
you for my tour i'm ready for
our next stop so you guys stay tuned for
that
that looks like so much fun it really
does so much history down there too
all right